[Music]
in our morning rounds a treatment
offerings hope for millions of sleep
apnea patients the disorder causes
people to stop breathing when they're
asleep an estimated 22 million Americans
suffer from sleep apnea it puts them at
greater risk for diabetes heart disease
stroke and memory loss patients who are
older overweight and male are generally
most at risk
David Begnaud shows us the new option
helping some patients David good morning
Nora good morning for those who struggle
with sleep apnea treatments like the
CPAP machine can be hard to sleep with
they don't always work and a lot of
people just can't get a full night's
sleep with it but now there's a new FDA
approved device called inspire and it's
gaining popularity for some people it's
a last resort their life literally
depends on it the Cleveland Clinic named
this kind of treatment number 2 on its
list of top medical innovations for 2018
we met a woman who finally found relief
after more than two decades of trying to
get a good night's rest I wasn't
breathing I wasn't getting the correct
amount of oxygen my thought process had
gone PEGI siravo's memory got so bad her
family thought she had dementia the 59
year old was so exhausted she says she
could barely do her job as a nurse so
people were noticing it but you were too
I was too knew something wasn't right I
knew not as quickly as they did but I
knew I was in trouble Peggy has severe
obstructive sleep apnea where her throat
muscles relax blocking her airway and
disrupting her sleep on average she
stops breathing 53 times an hour
that's nearly once every minute during a
night sleep give me an example of a
knife up for hours maybe sleep - this is
the area where I would sleep she tried
other treatments take the mask bring it
over my face like this she did not find
relief from the CPAP machine a common
treatment that delivers constant
pressurized air the CPAP wasn't getting
the job done so you needed oxygen on top
of that exactly and then that didn't
work that's when they introduced me to
inspire and save
life inspire is a pacemaker-like device
implanted in the chest
it senses when your breathing slows down
and sends an electric pulse to the
tongue to stimulate it forward keeping
the airway open this has been
revolutionary it's been a game-changer
dr. Maurits Boone is Peggy's doctor at
Thomas Jefferson Memorial Hospital in
Philadelphia she'd given up she had
memory issues she was miserable this is
not a benign diseases that this is a
killer and it actually shortens people's
lives a few months after having the
inspired device implanted you just need
to relax and breathe normally Peggy went
to a sleep lab to see how it was working
for me when her calm okay good night
they ran tests throughout the night and
early the next morning dr. Boone
revealed the results
so before we activated the device we
have all sorts of problems this is
basically your brain saying I'm not
breathing I need to do something about
it and after we activate device it's
perfect look at your oxygen nice stable
flatline staying around 96 97 % so this
as good as it gets
okay and as far as I'm concerned this is
a cure this is awesome a study in the
New England Journal of Medicine found
that more than two-thirds of patients
experience less sleep apnea after
getting the implant it was like sleeping
with a herd of elephants for years all
Peggy and her husband David wanted was a
good night's rest and now they're
finally getting it I'm gonna show you
every night Peggy turns on the implant
right before going to sleep what's it
like to sleep now great turn myself on
go to sleep and I sleep and then I get
up and I turn myself off and I have a
normal day like you and everybody else
come here max come here doodles it
doesn't work for everybody but man it
worked for you it sure did it saved my
life
now inspire is not for everyone it's
only for moderate to severe cases like
Peggy and like any surgery there is a
risk of infection for Peggy she says her
memory is back
100% and she's sleeping great at night
now the device costs around $20,000 not
including the surgery it's not cheap and
his insurance coverage so insurance it's
a case-by-case basis her doctor had to
kind of nudge the insurance company
along but they do well she must really
live her husband after staying on
national TV it sounds like that is
really great news so did she wear a mask
when she's got the info not anymore
not anymore and when she turns it on if
she talks it sounds like she's having a
stroke but other than that she feels
nothing she could just feel it pulsating
her tongue forward a life-saving no it
is absolutely great